well hundreds of military veterans are
suing the manufacturing company 3m
claiming it knowingly sold defective
earplugs these complaints come after the
Department of Justice settled a lawsuit
with the company in July it was over
allegations that the company defrauded
the government by selling ear plugs with
dangerous design defects to the military
for more than a decade our dr. Jon
LaPook met two veterans who say the
combat earplugs failed to prevent
catastrophic injuries including hearing
loss John good morning good morning 3m
agreed to pay nine point 1 million
dollars to the government but admitted
no liability I spoke with servicemen who
deployed in Afghanistan and Iraq where
they were near the firing with small
arms heavy artillery and rockets until
that 3m settlement they believe their
hearing loss was par for the course
we are told these devices are gonna save
our hearing and that's what we do we use
them yeah I mean the basic expectation
is that you can rely on your training in
your equipment Joseph's junk and David
Henderson served in the US military for
three and six years respectively junk
says he joined the army as part of
family tradition and Henderson felt a
duty to his country after 9/11 they both
relied on these earplugs to protect them
in training and combat everybody was
just under the impression that he's
particularly earplugs were doing their
job you thought they worked everybody
thought they worked and you're trusting
the Armed Forces
oh you're trusting certainly the
contractor assigned to provide that
equipment we've just been told that this
is the equipment you get and it's the
best out there it's gonna save your
hearing later on we found out that it
didn't really protect our hearing that
much at all a joint lawsuit filed by the
government and by mold X a competitor of
3m the manufacturer of the year plugs
alleged 3m was aware prior to selling
the earplugs to the military that
testing procedures and fitting
instructions were unlawfully manipulated
and it also claimed they sold the plugs
from 2003 to 2015 without disclosing the
design defect
it wasn't an omission it wasn't
something missed it was deliberately
lying to gain money and hurting our
servicemembers last month Junkin
Henderson filed civil complaints against
3m
claiming the company did not adequately
warned of the defects or adequately
warned how to wear the earplugs from
what I remember guys would you know put
them in and like they have bigger ear
canals so would go all the way in and
sort of get stuck in there or you had
guys that will put them in and they'd
still be able to hear absolutely
everything but you have so many other
things to worry about in particular to
safety or your you know your physical
well-being so you have to triage your
worries sure you'll worry bucket right
absolutely at the top was staying alive
and hearing was kind of like to the
bottom of the list
they say they both suffer from partial
hearing loss and a condition known as
tinnitus described as a high-pitched
hissing sound moment you stopped hearing
sounds around you is the moment the
ringing gets a little out of this what
it's quiet
what is quiet what's peace we I know for
me personally I don't have it all I hear
is ringing if there's no noise around me
so you're hearing some sound 24/7 at all
times if I do not have noise around me
it's maddening it is torture according
to the Department of Veterans Affairs
tinnitus is the most common disability
experienced by veterans with over 2.7
million receiving benefits for it our
military personnel are exposed to
extreme levels of noise dr. thomas
roland of nyu langone health explained
that sound enters not only through the
ear canal but also through something
known as bone conduction one sound
strikes the bone of our skull the bone
moves with the sound even if you
completely block the ear sound above a
certain level I can still get to the
inner ear through bone conduction and
still be very damaging he says that any
year plug even one perfectly designed
cannot prevent bone conduction of loud
sound through the skull to the inner ear
these year plugs have a dangerous design
flaw Andrew Duffy represents over two
dozen veterans who use these ear plugs
the goal is to send a message to 3m and
other companies that you cannot defraud
the United States of America and have
the consequences be the health and
well-being of our military members is
there any defense and saying no ear plug
no matter how good would ever protect
you from
the percussive wave the shockwave that
could also be doing damage to years I
couldn't say yes or no as a soldier
you're putting something in your ear
that's gonna stop that sound wave from
hitting your inner ear in the sensitive
parts of your ear that allow you to hear
I know you know this well but no
settlement you receive is going to get
your hearing back and get rid of the
tinnitus you can't put a price on that
you can't put a price on one of your
senses on your enjoyment of life of
maybe tranquil peace and quiet or how I
used to enjoy music I can't I can't
enjoy music like I used to
where does that leave you guys still
very angry still still wanting you know
wanting to you know raise raise
awareness to our you know fellow service
members yeah to get the word out go get
tested go you know go to the doctor but
then you know also wanting 3m to own up
to it to explain them more we can maybe
start with an apology those earplugs
have been discontinued and the
Department of Justice declined to
comment on which earplugs that the
military currently uses 3m told us it
has a long history of partnering with
the US military and continues to make
products to protect our troops it denies
the earplugs word effectively designed
I'm so glad you did this story and it's
a reminder too that our veterans who
come back and may appear healthy if
they're not limited when they are still
suffering the effects and trauma of war
it is we can't see yes and I think he
said it best when he said he can't put a
price on one of your senses right he's
never gonna be the same and he was so
poetically described his love of music
which you know really interrupt yeah
it's very very sad story but I'm also
glad that all these years I've been
saying tonight is wrong John I think
it's tonight's no trust me it's tomato
tomahto but in this case it's I'm glad
you brought that story to thank you
people need to know about that
thank you dr. Luke